on this episode I talk about Facebook
video versus YouTube I talked about
bathroom advertising and I talked about
what musicians should do in 2016 18 20
22 you ask questions and I answer them
this is the askgaryvee
[Music]
what's up everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 78 of
the ask gary vee show first and foremost
i need to give a tremendous welcome to
my new wide receiver Brandon Marshall
the gestures traded for the Bears
receiver Brandon Marshall I'm excited
about it thrilled with the fifth round
pick exchange we'll see how it works out
I'm sure a lot of you leave comments
saying he's old he's washed up and this
and that that's fine
I'll do that deal uh but something ye
still live-streaming on meerkat I like
that people are enjoying that India's
here with her long hair show it show it
and let's get right into the show Nicole
asks I just bought an indoor billboard
company how do you feel about
advertising in the bathroom Nicole I'm
about to throw a huge curveball that's a
clayton kershaw left-handed curveball ah
it's a fantasy baseball time you're
gonna start getting a lot of fantasy
baseball reference's over the next three
to four weeks five weeks six weeks seven
weeks um eight weeks I think that I love
this see one thing that people don't
realize is I've spewed about how I think
Superbowl commercials are grossly
underpriced I think people think that I
hate all traditional media and it's just
about social the truth is I just care
about the attention graph show me where
the eyes and ears are and I'll show you
something I believe in I believe that
when I go peepee and I see a sign right
here now look the truth is flip it to me
the truth is more and more lately when I
go peepee
I'm doing this right so that do you do
you look at your phone when your pee
step on check Alex check d-roc okay four
four four
so do I think the value of urinal signs
is as high as it was three years ago I
don't do I think that there's still
probably undervalue because people do
pay attention I do they're better than
other outdoor medium stuff but the
vulnerability to uh to these urinal
signage which I've always been a
historic huge fan of is the phone
culture watch this Stephan did you uh
did you look at your phone while you
were peeing three years ago you you me
neither
and that's
super interesting Chris asks if Apple
could build a car converse a DS build a
smartphone Chris everybody can be in
everybody's business if you're good
enough could Dion and Bo Jackson play
both football and baseball they could
they were good enough could I neither
you know like I mean the answer is
absolutely
remember Nintendo started as a playing
card company Sony which made televisions
decided to become a major player in the
video game space Microsoft became a
major player in the video game space uh
Mobile's going you know with the watch
the Apple watch things incredible Apple
as a phone provider was a brain twist we
just forget cuz it just happened
what's that you like it you like the
show the Mayo is all excited um he never
gets excited up so you know I think the
answer is yes but when Mercedes has to
do is have the talent internally to be
able to pull it off but I believe that
the internet is shrinking the middle and
infrastructure costs North Yorks looking
at but I I believe that the internet is
shrinking the middle and infrastructure
costs which make me believe that anybody
can go into anybody's business if they
have the talent and so I think that will
play itself out so I do believe that
this will be a good video to make it
I'll enjoy watching this in 15 years
I do believe three to five to ten major
companies in certain genres as we see
Google going into self-driving cars and
the question at hand which is a great
question I I can see I'm going to make
some predictions here ganado
and I'm not usually write with my
predictions I'm a fast advisor and then
I execute I'm not a great predictor but
I will say this Nike feels like a
company to me that will pull off being
in a business that none of us can wrap
our head around right now I'm going with
Nike I also think Starbucks has the
potential DNA to do it and then I think
somebody rogue and old that we
disrespect whether it's IBM or G you
know I think somebody more traditional
is going to go into a business that none
of us would expect and by the way before
I go to the next question your snow shot
was tremendous and that's why we love
having people ask questions on Instagram
Broadway's next hit you
glass we're an improv comedy group that
performs both in New York City and
throughout the country how do we use
social media to get input about each
town we'll be performing in ahead of
time so that we can create unforgettable
shows full of in the know references
Broadway's next hit musical let me
answer this question for you it's called
a very simple tactic that I used to over
index in social in two thousand seven
eight and nine it's called listening you
go to twitter.com slash search and you
search the zip code of the town you're
coming into and it will show you every
single person tweeting in that town you
read the comments and then you make
references to being in the know you're
welcome hi it's Tanya Mercer and the
question is about Facebook videos in one
day I posted a facebook video that got
twenty five hundred views it took me
that long to get that many views in one
year on YouTube do I continue with
YouTube or should I focus on Facebook
tanya great question first of all I want
to make sure that you got 2500 views and
not 2,500 impressions so I need you to
pause go back and look at the
impressions numbers and the views
numbers because that's where people are
getting a little bit confused tactically
practicioner lately in the trenches on
facebook the answer to your question is
both like you should be making youtube
videos you should be making Facebook
videos most of the content should be the
same you're able to kind of if you edit
you now have the luxury of these
tremendous athletes and they can and
they can edit and and and do some
screenshot previews and do some
different things that are more native to
to Facebook more native to YouTube your
call to actions to share can be
different there's some nuances but I
have a feeling if you create a very
effective pre-roll and post roll that
are both native to Facebook and YouTube
the answer is both because you never
know where somebody's going to see you
and then it allows you to pop one view
on YouTube can change your life
it could be Oprah jsk drums ask what
advice would you have for musicians
wanting to make their living playing
music in the 21st century
Justin thank you so much for a question
amazing picture great job to have your
community give you some love and it
allowed me to see this question I'm
really excited to answer this question
you know I think the answer is you know
as a musician you need to be everywhere
where the people that care about your
genre music are and obviously the youth
is an over indexing play so look if
you're not on soundcloud if you're not
on snapchat and vine and Instagram then
you're not living to a 25 year old old
and under and I think that's an
important place for you to be so one you
need to be putting out content
everywhere once you build a leverage
there's ways to monetize right brands
are gonna continue to pay for music live
events will happen I think what really
matters is creating content and putting
them out on all these platforms and then
interacting with your audience right so
it's not good enough to just put out the
song and get it use disrobe kit and get
it out everywhere and then it's on every
platform great it's on SoundCloud and
iTunes and Spotify great that's fine but
then how do you actually harness like
what is being a musician it's always
been look Grateful Dead and fish those
are very successful bands because they
actually have a community and what
happens is people that are very hardcore
about music I'm not one of them but the
reason they make fun of pop music is
it's fleeting right if it sits for a
second and then goes away the best pop
music you know the Madonna's the Michael
Jackson's the Justin Timberlake's they
cultivated community you have bet you
know it's so funny I was like woe is me
you can't make money with tools anymore
do you know many people have popped and
made money because of YouTube and vine
and snapchat and Instagram that would
have never been signed fifteen years ago
and then would have had to just go on
and do with it so what's happened my
friend is there's less people at the
tippy-top there's less fit there's less
acts right there's not 50 people anymore
making a good drill Ian just on selling
music but what's happened is the
Internet has created a longer tail and
so there's a lot more people right now a
lot more people making thousands and
tens of thousands and hundreds of
thousands and I've got to tell you
something if you're an artist and
musicians are you just want to be able
to do your art you know many people are
happy making forty one thousand dollars
a year from adsense or
random show or things that nature who
now because a modern technology can make
41 thousand a year and play their music
who had to do something else
15 years ago to make forty one thousand
because you couldn't make forty one
thousand playing your music so my friend
wearing a long tail we're in the long
tail you wanna make enough to really
crush it and play your music well then
you've got to care about the audience
one by one by one by one and you got to
do things for your audience and what I
mean by that is you've got to start
using tools like meerkat and create
behind-the-scenes footage you have to
keep innovating you have to keep making
that connection you have to keep taking
away the velvet rope I mean look meerkat
is a preview to the fact that I'm going
to be wearing wearable devices and you
guys are gonna be following me
everywhere I go all the time always
Truman Show [ __ ] the Vaynerchuk show
it's coming get ready
get your [ __ ] popcorn because I'm
coming at you and that connection is the
game
so that's episode 78 in the bag all the
people watching on YouTube I need you to
subscribe to the podcast I'm getting
very obsessed with this right now
getting a little competitive throwing a
little bit of right hooks let's link
these up d-roc down below whatever
please and review the show I need that
love please that means a lot to me
question of the day will you when this
technology comes will you write will you
Truman show your life or will you
consume Truman shows give me a breakdown
0 putting out content 100% consumption
well 0 and 0 because you won't do either
a hundred putting it out and 0 consuming
tell me how you're going to break down
that future you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them
by the way India did a [ __ ] job and
didn't show me the bathroom ads while I
was explaining it was urinals I get it
but you could have stopped me while I
was doing my whole urinal like you know
explanation those doors I like I mean
you know again it's a shock value they
haven't been indoors in the past and
again in five years we'll all tune them
out but for the first beginnings I kind
of like it I mean the bathroom is a
captivated place I'm a fan of marketing
there I want to be in charge of picking
the picture we may have to go in a bath
take picture with meerkat all right
let's go
[Music]
yeah yeah
[Music]